[Musique]
bonjour bonjour a été calé programme du
jour le programme du jour c'est un appel
à la rieuse
c'est à dire 1 afin de vivre deux foies
novillars jc faire la paire sauvage dans
la paix régionale
on va accompagner le corps avec du riz
campagne à six compagnies breuil où
faut-il pour faire tout ça
aidez-nous four de la ventrèche du riz
du piercing de l'oignon des tomates du
serpolet ou du temps comme on veut de
line des poivrons des pignons de la
farine du sel du poivre bien entendu et
notre petit tapis de graines et vous
l'avez partir d'exemples eux aussi et du
vin blanc bien entendu pour faire la
source
alors vas blanc et notre lapin oui alors
pour commencer avec notre lapin que
faisons nous et puis on va commencer par
le nettoyer alors il faut sinon ça se
fait tout seul vous allez voir
encore faut-il savoir mais là vous
coupez la peau un peu là voilà et c'est
tout et après tout se faire la main on
lui enlève la chemise sa part tout seul
vous en avez l'habitude suis sûr que
vous êtes toujours fait ça toute votre
vie je me trompe pas non
de la paille tenu malgré tout les que
fait-on maintenant on va s'occuper du
riz ont surtout du riz d'abord voilà
alors là plusieurs méthodes la vôtre n'a
plus simple un bol de riz et deux fois
son volume d'eau tout simplement ou
simplement c'est patrice accident non
non non et on va mettre voilà un oui et
là on n'a pas besoin de le couler vous
le reste et c'est tout et deux lignes au
col jamais il ne pourra jamais voilà un
peu de sel je n'en peux plus la voilà on
couvre et on allume peut-être ça vaut de
la nuit oui rares couleurs vous allez
comté de cuisson au four 10 minutes
alors vous savez quand il n'y a plus
d'eau il est prêt oui bien sûr voilà là
pas mal ça cuit
oui eh bien on va revenir alors la balle
en opération délicate nous menons vos
vidéos vos devis 2 voilà on prend le
foot au haut niveau la panse vous mettez
les deux doigts comme ça ne faut pas
pour aller ou pas nos tripes
oui mais voilà jusqu'en bas là on va
chercher tout ça elle a finalement si on
l'achète dans un magasin on peut
l'acheter sans avoir cette petite
besogne a sei voci rien de fait par lui
même délicate
oui il faut pas percé alors c'est là le
plus délicat découvrir sortir la vessie
et voilà messieurs que c'est ce qu'il
fallait pas faire le seul truc si cette
affaire est bien dans le milieu et c'est
bien comme ça on sait ce que c'est de
bien c'est comme ça qu'on apprend
ben oui il a fait fi fille on dit se
couchant c'est la meilleure des
démonstrations pour ceux qui auront à le
faire après alors ils avaient envie pour
le cochon
voilà c'est pas d'armatis de base de pas
dramatique non
voilà il a été bien laver et maintenant
vous le découper en morceaux découpés en
morceaux
je suis nombre de fois on va regarder
oui on va mettre ça dans notre cocotte
où vous avez mis quoi dans la cogneuse
de la grenaille canard que bien bien sûr
aux riches aux deux voila voila je vais
le sahara et le poivre et oui on l'a
fait la grèce je pense souvent qu'il
faut faire aujourd'hui ça le
supporterait même un peu plus marty ces
gens là et après je vais laisser dorer
un tout petit peu oui et je vais y
mettre mes oignons qu'on a coupé en
lamelles à voir mais il faut d'abord que
la fin soit bien doré sous x et voilà
que lorsqu'on a besoin n'est pas besoin
de tous les morceaux d'un coup gens là
nous avons pris deux morceaux et
l'arrière voilà les plus beaux la
phalange mmo noyau d'un sénat adoré
aussi là ça donne un très bon goût oui
parce que l'oignon ne gâche rien
toujours des unions en principe de tout
ceci ce prix de soif et saveurs
l'audience est la base de toutes ces
bonnes relations
voilà là on va laisser les autres c'est
bien ça et on va y rajouter des tomates
fraîches et iona la chance d'en avoir
mais très belle bâtisse nous on a la
chance de l'avoir
on est coupé leçon lavez vous les voulez
dans l'assiette d'abord pendant une
fusion évoquée directement ou
indirectement 9h08 pour s'allier tous
ces trucs là voilà on est coupé en
morceaux
je vis très simplement dit non plus sur
toute la cuisine à puce est la meilleure
à condition d'avoir de bons produits
frais y aura des jardins qui nous coûte
ont tous noté prix du lait parce qu'il
ya des tendances on a pris soin avant
d'être pull ras m elle fait cela pour
faire voler et buteur alors le relais
c'est du terme souvent réservé alors
nous devons partir et que vous avez été
cueillir ce matin au bord de la route au
bord de la route au bord des routes au
bordel
desbarats dos à plus de passion va
réclamer des flux dans les landes bien
entendu dans les forêts de pins ça donne
une heure mais l'oms en avant par faire
que si on en a pas que les beatles live
on en rajoutera après on va lier le
canard est oui là et maintenant
recouvrir et on va laisser mijoter tous
sont tous à la gloire je vais vous
appartient cauberg
merci voilà
rim a été il me paraît très bien les
gens ne veulent pas les clubs dans un
halo récurrents grandes compagnies air
puisque c'est ce que vous avez vu on
vole on ne rit et puis on va mettre dans
la graisse des oignons mrc dans la tête
de taylor agressent très chaude soit
saisi
on y en a c'est pas bien alors on à
l'investissement et pendant ce temps je
vais faire les lardons vous tirer un peu
le rio vous faire de la place je vais
alors les et la ventrèche votre ventre
est habituel saler poivrer
oui on a des zones grises à fond et on
va faire nos lardons mais nous n'avons
pas les délits faire des démos et des
petits lardons établi déchets on ne va
pas remettre des marchés n'ont pu
processus vers la quantité de 3 proche
de l'art dont la caméra en plastique qui
entoure
oui je puis surtout qu'aucune somme qui
ne sera adapté à notre union est entrain
de cuivre alors les petits lardons on va
les faire douter
parce qu'il faut pas les grains de riz
ce n'est pas gros et très bien et qu'est
ce qui se passe avec notre lapin ce qui
pouvait pas y ajouter le vin c'est
l'instant on va la mettre à chauffer le
vern
bon à la pana que vous allez faire les
lardons moi je vais m'occuper de mon
père alors comment il l'atteint on va le
regarder je vais d'abord beaucoup plus
vert alors si dusablon du vin rouge et
du vin blanc un blanc un blème blanc-sec
oui on va faire brûler dia bien chauffé
où elle avait enlevé tout est bien sûr
je vais regarder
makoko seulement la peine que vous allez
bien vous montrer comment le membre
allez devant la boutique c'est bien
simple on a bien une idée reçue comme il
est beau commence à prendre ben ali a
pas que je me brûle il est beau et la
voilà le vin blanc bout on va l'allumer
là on va le laisser brûler un tout petit
peu et on va le mettre dans notre
console pendant ce temps voilà là rien
et moi ça c'est joli comme tout ça
commence à brûler ça continue à brûler
la alors assez jolis seins ça va être
très sympa et nous on nous annonce un
rebond comme il faut aussi alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez bien nous
venions la lumière semble d'avis voilà
allons-y démarré son exercice avec un
panier et on est l'emploi qui continue à
errer dans cette fois que vous mettez
quoi maintenant maintenant remettre
dollars d'or devrait mettre un peu de
gras et on va y mettre dollars dont là
que vous avez bien immense et voilà que
tout ça ça va faire bien dans la
banlieue parce que l'hiver n'a pas du
tout comme légume et bien sûr alors il
faut bien sûr y faisait là on ne parle
pas encore du travail
et comme il faut je vais laren remuer
ceci et on va recouvrir entre cocotte se
passe autrement tout le vert va
s'évaporer
oui il ne restera plus du tout de jus je
vais réduire un tout petit peu le feu
voilà et couvrir et couvrir les trois
ans que vous en faites des travaux assez
on est mélangé avec des lardons
on va laisser revenir un peu notre
valeureux chez on va y ajouter non
poivrons ils sont déjà cuit alors il
faut pas les faire cuire le fait juste
du fait d'un bug ou avec les lardons
c'est tout et ça parce que c'est pas la
saison est donnée par un drone
concernées pendant les concerts
ou alors j'ai eu envie de venir ici je
vais mettre un petit peu de froid vous
voyez vous oui un petit peu de sel parce
que la bosse pas traversé l'année où
l'on puisse se terminer on va les
mélanger à vos souris
voilà c'est bien mais là non et on
réduit tout c'est en remuant tout y est
c'est terminé c'est pas la mort du petit
cheval et voilà le riz campagnard que
jolie appétissant et ça sent bon et
notre lapin notaires se définit pendant
ce temps qu'est ce qui lui arrive à
l'image virile quand vous allez voir on
va un terme très vite de finir on va où
là que je me vois ça c'est des risques
du métier
on va mettre un petit peu d'ail bien si
normalement il faut lapider
oui non à l'arbitraire oui c'est pour
lui qu'ils du pur du bien du goût voilà
une gousse wii ont maintenant pignon
dedans ça c'est local c'est râlant des
rendez vous couvrir on va recouvrir ne
sert à rien de faire si là dedans ah oui
c'est vrai un chemin je suis vert merci
merci beaucoup
un petit chemin de perçu ces jolis
essais terminés et on va les recouvrir
on va retourner et recouvrir tout ça
ces prêts ces prêts voilà là et on va le
laisser là dix minutes avec les u21
petit peu c'est fini de recettes faciles
le lapin à la rionnaise et le riz
campagnard des recettes par faire des
sonorités ma chère facile et vous pouvez
pas rater
alors pourquoi ne pas essayer bon
courage et à bientôt
roy merci à tous au revoir
[Musique]